>> Tucker: HE COMMITTED A
CRIME.
HE WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR BEING
UNAUTHORIZED DISCLOSURE OF
UNCLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
YET ACCORDING TO COMMIE, THIS
WAS LEGAL BECAUSE IT WASN'T
LEAKING.
IT WAS QUOTE, COMMUNICATED.
>> BUT YOU DID LEAK MEMOS, I
MEAN, IS IT OKAY FOR SOMEBODY AT
THE FBI TO LEAK SOMETHING, AN
INTERNAL DOCUMENT, EVEN IF IT'S
NOT CLASSIFIED?
>> >> I DON'T LEAK MEMOS.
I ASKED HER FRIENDS COMMUNICATE
THE SUBSTANCE OF ONE
UNCLASSIFIED --
>> CAN I FINISH MY ANSWER.
ONE CLASSIFIED MEMO TO THE
MEDIA.
>> I ASKED A FRIEND TO
COMMUNICATE THE CONTENT OF THE
MEMO.
>> AS IT TURNS OUT, THE FBI HAS
DETERMINED THAT COMMIES LEAKED
MEMOS DID IN FACT CONTAINED
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
CALL ME FAILED TO REDACT THAT.
>> THIS WAS THE HEAD OF THE FBI.
THIS IS A GUY WHO KNEW WHAT THE
RULES WERE AND IGNORE THEM.
HE COMMITTED A CRIME.
>> CALL ME ADMITS THAT HE
COMMITTED A CRIME, , AND TIDILY
FOR COMPLETE FOR POLITICAL
REASONS.
>> HE WAS ABLE TO FIND LEAKERS
AND MAIL IT TO THE DOORS OF
MESSAGE.
I SAID THAT HE HAD >> SHOULDN'T
YOU BE ANNEALED TO THE DOOR THEN
YOU BE ANNEALED TO THE DOOR THE?
AREN'T YOU A LEAGUER?
>> PLENTY OF PEOPLE LEAK
INFORMATION TO AN NONCLASSIFIED
REPORT IS IN THE WHITE HOUSE
GETS UPSET ABOUT APPEARED >> THE
FBI GETS UPSET WHEN PEOPLE MAKE
UNAUTHORIZED DISCLOSURES OF
PROTECTED INFORMATION.
I INTENTIONALLY GAVE THIS
INFORMATION TO A FRIEND.
I WANTED IT TO GET OUT INTO THE
MEDIA.
>> I WANTED IT TO GET OUT IN THE
A MEMO WITH CLASSIFIED MATERIAL
IN IT.
WHAT YOU JUST SAW IS A
CONFESSION.
COMEY ADMITTED EVERYTHING ON
CAMERA.
IF YOU ARE PROSECUTING THIS
CASE, IT WOULD BE OPEN AND SHUT
BUT IT WON'T BE PROSECUTED.
APPARENTLY COMEY WILL NEVER BE
TRIED FOR THE CRIMES HE
COMMITTED.
ACCORDING TO THE HILLS JOHN
SOLOMON, THE DOJ HAS DECIDED NOT
TO PROSECUTE JAMES COMEY ON THE
GROUNDS THAT PUNISHING HIM FOR
BREAKING THE LAW WOULD SEEM,
COLD, PETTY AND VINDICTIVE.
OF COURSE, PETTY AND VINDICTIVE
DESCRIBES THE CULTURE OF THE FBI
UNDER JIM COMEY.
PATTY AND PETTY AND VINDICTIVE
IS THE REGENT REASON ROGER STONE
HAS BEEN TREATED MORE
HARSHLY THAN JEFFREY EPSTEIN
EVER WAS.
PETTY AND VINDICTIVE SUMS UP THE
ENTIRE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
AND THE EFFORT TO DESTROY
DONALD TRUMP'S ENTIRE LIFE.
HE ABUSED THE PUBLIC'S TRUST
PEERED IN 2016, HE REPEATEDLY
INJECTED HIMSELF INTO THE
POLITICAL ARENA AND BY HIS OWN
ADMISSION, HE CONSIDERED THE
POLITICAL EFFECT OF HIS ACTIONS
WHEN HE DID SO.
HIS SUBORDINATES MEANWHILE, PETE
MOLLY PETER STRZOK AND
LISA PAGE, LOW SOME PEOPLE,
REPEATEDLY CONSPIRED TO USE
FBI RESOURCES TO SABOTAGE THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN DIDN'T
LIKE.
THEN IN 2017, THERE WAS A CLIMAX
PEERED ACCORDING TO REPORTS,
CALL ME LIGHTS OF THE PRESS AND
HIS BOSS TELLING HIM HE WAS NOT
UNDER INVESTIGATION.
IN FACT, COMEY WASN'T
MANEUVERING TO BEGIN AN
INVESTIGATION.
THEN WITH THE LEAKS THAT HE JUST
ADMITTED TO ON CAMERA YOU SAW,
COMEY LAUNCHED THE RUSH HOLT
INVESTIGATION.
THERE NEVER WAS.
IT WAS NEVER JUSTIFIED.
IT WAS ALWAYS JUST A HILLARY
CAMPAIGN TALK IMPLANT.
AN EXCUSE FOR HER TO HUMILIATE
AN ELECTION.
EVERYONE KNEW THAT.
BUT INSTEAD OF HER HATE BEHAVING
RESPONSIBLY, HE INDULGED THE
SAME CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT HAS
PUSHED FOR TWO YEARS.
RESCUING JIM COMEY FOR HIS
CRIMES THAT HE ADMITTED SHE
WOULD NOT BE PETTY OR